welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled
how do we bring lung cancer diagnostic
biomarkers to the clinic
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
pierre macion
assistant professor of medicine
department of medicine
vanderbilt university school of medicine
nashville tennessee
dr maccion attends a pulmonary and
critical care inpatient service
and the pulmonary outpatient clinic at
the nashville va medical center
his research interests include genetic
and proteomic strategies
for the early detection of lung cancer
chemo preventative strategies
for the primary and reoccurrence of lung
cancer
and investigation of the role of genomic
abnormalities
in lung cancer for a complete biography
on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following this presentation
please join me in welcoming dr pierre
macien i will now turn the presentation
over to him well thank you very much for
this introduction
and hello everybody it's my pleasure to
be here today to
discuss with you how we bring lung
cancer diagnostic biomarkers
to the clinic as a
disclosure the message to remember is
that
i work with many industries i typically
don't get funding from them
and therefore i remain independent from
the industries in general
but the work that i'm going to be
presenting
is funded by the national cancer
institute the department of defense
and the veterans administration so lung
cancer is a big problem as you all know
you probably all know somebody who have
suffered from that disease who may have
died from it who are currently
struggling with it
it's a very important killer it's a
number one cancer killer in the us
and in the world and if you look at all
diseases that are leading to
a death the respiratory death
corresponds to about 50 of all deaths
among those
lung cancer is the biggest culprit 38
of all people dying of respiratory
diseases are dying of lung cancer
so when you think about the natural
history of
lung cancer it's not perfectly known but
what we know is people
eventually develop a risk over a long
period of time
they may start smoking at the age of 10
or 15
get on with their lives and most of them
are diagnosed at around the age
of 70. at that time only
25 would benefit from a cure
so our job is to try to diagnose the
disease early why are we interested in
that
is because what when you diagnose it
early
you have a better chance of surviving
it's true for most diseases it's just
common sense
detect the nodule early on and it should
be able to operate on it
and offer a patient a cure earlier than
at the typical time of diagnosis when
only
25 of them will survive
if we diagnose it very early on 80 or 85
percent of them could survive the
disease
so there's a great impetus to develop
strategies for early detection
so why is it important particularly
important in tennessee is because we are
suffering from
an endemic uh area of lung cancer you
see on this map whatever is brown and
dark brown
corresponds to the center of this
endemic area
the percentage and actually the
prevalence of lung cancer
in this south east part of the
country is about 40 higher than in the
rest of the country
and it maps pretty well with the
intensity of smoking
which makes sense because smoking is the
number one cause of cancer-related
mortality
so we have to do something about this
disease and if you don't know about
yet there is a screening strategy
for early detection of lung cancer
and this is lung cancer ct screening
there are two studies represented on
this slide
on the left hand side the results from
the national lung screening trial
that demonstrates that not only the
number of
cancers that we diagnose in the lung
cancer screening are greater
but more importantly the death rate
associated with lung cancer screening is
lower meaning that we are saving lives
in fact we save 20 percent
a decrease in relative debt from lung
cancer
with low dose chest ct and these results
were
very much mirrored by another study
done in europe in the netherlands and in
belgium
where they found that lung cancer
incidence was also increasing with
screening but that the death rate was
lower
actually their death rate from lung
cancer
with the lung cancer screening strategy
was even
better than what we found in the u.s
they didn't find a
20 relative decrease in mortality
but up to 35
so that brought the entire world to be
excited about lung cancer screening
and try to implement this strategy one
of the biggest problem is that
this strategy is
still at the beginning you would expect
that
high-risk individual would undergo lung
cancer screening
but about only 10 of them are following
that strategy at the moment
it took very long time for mammography
to be obtained by most women
or colonoscopy to be successful and we
hope that we can
fast and and you know accelerate
the implementation of lung and cancer
screening because
it saves lives if i show you this
chest ct you recognize the right lung
here the left lung on the right hand
side and you see the nodule on the right
upper lobe
that nodule is dense speculated about
one and a half to two centimeter
diameter it's a lung cancer
that's an estimate it's a guess it's a
probability that this is likely to be a
lung cancer
and i can tell you that because i see
that there's a culprit on the chest ct
the culprit is outside the chest you see
here there's a lighter in the station
pocket
and a pack of cigarettes so now we're
licking causes and diseases
but this is anecdotal but this slide is
to tell you that lung cancer
detection can be
complicated and i told you that it's
related to
uh the fact that chest city
does not always give you the answer
and here's why because not only lung
cancer is very prevalent in the
southeast
but it's also true that this region of
the country
is also the area where the highest
concentration of histoplasmosis
is encountered and this fungal disease
is an
infectious disease can
look and appear on justice d
just like this one so it's a big
compounder
it's a big struggle in the southeast
region of the united states
so now we think okay we can use chess
ct and um is it the panacea
for lung cancer screening and we're
going to save most
lives i told you we don't save
everybody's life with low-dose chest ct
this slide gives you a little idea of
what proportion we are really saving
if you're thinking about all people
dying of lung cancer
in 2020 we have about 160
000 dying of this disease
if you were to uh screen
according to the national lung screening
trial
criteria for screening meaning that your
55 years of age and less than 75
and if you have smoke for 30 years at
least a pack a day and you haven't quit
more than 15 years ago
we could eventually save 40 to 7 000
lives out of these 160 thousand but in
fact
we are not as good as that because if we
had to
implement lucas screening in that
population we would
effectively we could save up to 12 000
lives
and 12 000 lives is only about 8
of the entire population dying of lung
cancer so we have a long way to go but
now we have at least a strategy
for early detection of lung cancer and
yet we have to go
a lot better than just
lung cancer screening with the current
guidelines
there's a big effort currently to
actually expand
the population we may screen and we hope
to save many more lives this way
so what is the problem the problem is
when you screen for lung cancer
and i want to come up with a strategy to
detect these
nodules we have it by chest ct this is a
nodule that looks very suspicious
now not all lung nodules are cancerous
and we want to find a biomarker strategy
or some type of imaging strategy
to tell us
in a non-invasive way which of these
nodules is going to be malignant
nodules is a big problem you see this
1.6 million nodules
in the united states diagnosed every
year
very small number are going to be
cancers and yet
many of them undergo surgery
the nodules that we worried about are
those that are 6 to 30 millimeter in
diameter that are non-calcified
and we can bring them into different
risk groups if you have a tiny nodule
that's really smooth it's going to be
low risk
less than 5 if you have a big nodule
like this one
speculative dense and showing
characteristics of high risk
your probability of cancer is very high
the difficult
zone is the intermediate zone and that's
the area that we are trying to
improve our diagnostic in a non-invasive
way
we hope that detailed imaging can help
us with this
and we hope that eventually biomarkers
will come to the rescue
so this lung cancer nodule is a big
problem
it's um 28 billion dollars a year
and it's about the same cost of what
osteoporosis management and treatment
represents in the u.s so it's a big
healthcare burden
so how do we eventually make progress
well we have big problems because
nodules are not all the same you see
this small nodule in the left lower lobe
here
was present in 2005 and this nodule
remained stable
over six years and never changed
this is most likely a lung cancer but a
rather indolent cancer
now some of these cancer are not so
indolent
and if you look at this slide here this
nigel diagnosed in 2005 start
growing slowly over time and finally in
2013
uh benefit the patient had a pet scan
done he was
active very hot on pet
and the patient underwent a resection of
that left upper lobe
and what was found is a tumor an
adenocarcinoma
well the same patient actually over time
start developing another nodule
you can't even see nothing here but look
at here there's something
coming up over time this nigel was
growing the question was
is it the same disease or a different
disease the same cell that went to a
different over the lung
it happened to be a different tumor on
the same patient
also a lung adenocarcinoma so the
message here is that
although lung nodules come in different
forms some can
remain in the land and some can become
aggressive and it's difficult to
identify them
the last nodule that i showed you that
was a cancer was not that active
so imaging is not the answer to
everything
so what's the biggest challenge the
challenge
is that we have a large portion of
people with
intermediate risk for lung cancer the
nodule we don't really know what to do
with
and we want to reduce that group because
this is the group where we make
most of the mistakes and what we are uh
proposing here is that we basically
bring
some type of bowel marker to the rescue
we're gonna
we're gonna test all these individual in
yellow
and ask whether a biomarker can change
their group
classes maybe a portion of these people
can become
green meaning safe to follow over time
we re
rule out cancer in that group and the
converse may be true
some proportion of these people may be
higher risk and we bring them in
and we offer a biopsy because they are
more likely to be malignant
so these reclassification of the
intermediate group
from the yellow to a low-risk group in
grain or
high-risk group in red is the goal of
this effort
we are trying to deal with these tough
nodules
so would eventually a biomarker help us
here
is the question and we can talk briefly
about biomarkers and what
they need to show well biomarkers are
basically
a reflection of whether what we're
dealing with
may be either cancer or no cancer well
we have to make sure that we have an
assay that's accurate
and that's valid that it has been tested
in
other population that it causes a large
number of
of cancer to be diagnosed early and if
you diagnose it earlier
instead of diagnosing most people stage
three or four
you shift it to diagnosing stage one
where the diet
the prognosis is a lot better you can
survive
and up to 70 or 80 of people with stage
one lung cancer now survive
five years now we want to reduce the
number of false positive
and we wanted to make sure that whatever
biomarker brings in
uh eventually makes a big difference in
terms of it adds value to what the
current
standard of management management are
they're not the
strategy the biomarker that is an
imaging or blood biomarker must be cost
effective and eventually save lives
that's the ultimate goal
but i think that a reasonable target is
to demonstrate that we are
adding value to the current management
this is where we want biomarkers to be
so in collaboration with a group in the
united
kingdom we started looking at
imaging biomarkers and what we did is we
grabbed a large number of chess cts like
the one i showed you earlier
we had a total of 15 000
uh benign lung nodules from different
individuals
and about 932 cancer
and that population comes from the
natural lung screening trial
so we identified so many nodules and
from all these images
we developed an artificial intelligence
strategy to identify
what is cancer from what is benign and
then we decided that once we have our
artificial intelligence model we're
going to validate it
we're going to validate in three
different ways one within the same
trial the national long screening trial
and then in two independent courts one
from the
u.s and one from the uk and here is what
we found
we grouped that population we had to
deal with a large population
from the national lung screening trial
over 15 000 nodules
vanderbilt we had 116 and oxford 463
and then we tested our artificial
intelligence
model here in the nlst and validated in
these
different groups there are different
characteristics there's too many numbers
on this slide ignore it
but this is to tell you that we
basically trained in
one cohort and validated in two
independent cores
so how does this artificial intelligence
model works it's a prediction and
machine learning method
we call it lung cancer predictor
convolutional neural network
the neural network is basically taking a
bunch of images like you see in the ace
part of the slide and bringing them to a
computer
to have them recognize what is a cancer
and what is
a benign nodule and then we train the
classifier
to at the end gives us an answer as to
whether the image we have in front of us
is likely to be cancerous or not and
give us a percentage of
likelihood score of cancer let's say 75
chance that this is a cancer this is how
we train it in b
you see that in the training data set we
provide the
the artificial intelligence model
with three nodules two that are benign
one that's malignant and then
we give them a large number of nodules
and the better
uh the module the model gets a lot
better with the large number of nodules
so we end up with over 15 000 nodules
and train the model
if the model gets the answer wrong we
retrain the model we'll refine the model
there's an iterative aspect to this
training procedure and at the end we
give
the model unknown nodules and we ask
them tell us what it is
and then we see in what percentage of
the time we are accurate at determining
if this is a cancer
and this is a benign one so here
um i wanted to show you a little
video that illustrates
how we eventually
perform this analysis based on
the images that are selected on our
imaging record
we can actually download directly the
images
and you'll see that we screen through
the images really quickly there is a
nodule in the right
upper lobe we're going to identify
and select that nodule in the right
upper lobe find its center
click on the very center of the nodule
itself
and try to draw a sphere around it
now the nodule is going to be segmented
and we're going to ask a software to
give us a probability
of cancer and here we are the
probability of cancer in this particular
nodule is
98 very high risk for cancer
now we did this in the natural lung
screening trial data set
and what we showed is that compared to a
clinical model
as to uh whether this is malignant or
not
the uh the artificial intelligence
tool gives us better discrimination
these are called
uh receiver operating operative
characteristic curves
and you see that the pink curve is
better because it's more to the left and
to the top part of the slide
and it gives an accuracy that goes from
85 percent to 92 percent
these seven percent improvement in
accuracy don't seem like a large number
but it's a tremendous
improvement now if we try to validate
this in the
vanderbilt cohort or in the oxford
cohort
every time we beat the clinical
prediction alone
and the clinical prediction really
include the age the history of smoking
the history of cancer in the past how
big the nodule is and
whether his shape is irregular or
irregular
so our artificial intelligence model
is quite better and actually it allows
us
to reclassify about a third of the
nodules
back to this figure here if you see
these intermediate risk
nigel in yellow we were able to
reclassify
about a third of them into a lower risk
group a high risk group
what does that do well it actually
um decreases the number of
in not necessary procedures so
unnecessary procedures we do
and then also decrease the time to
diagnosis because we're
better and faster identifying the bad
guys when we rule
in disease so this is the
uh the state of the art now of this
biomarker which is an imaging biomarker
so where do we want to go there
we we have demonstrated that we have
discovered
a good model we have validated
analytically and in three different
cohorts
now we want to do a clinical utility
study and that clinical utility study
will tell you and me whether this is
going to help
patients get their diagnose done earlier
and with fewer procedures and whether
eventually this may save lives so we
need
to get to a proposal
of a clinical trial and to bring
patients and biomarkers
onto a train and the idea that we are
we are riding this train with our lung
nodules
and we want some bowel markers to be
tested to see whether
we are accurate and clinically useful
we're going to test a bunch of
biomarkers on the train we're going to
take some
on it and we're going to let some of
these biomarkers that are not useful
leave the train
and we'll arrive at destination
hopefully with a great
proposal so how do we propose to do this
in a randomized fashion what does it
mean if you
are let's say 60 years old and you
present with a lung nodule that's in
this
intermediate risk we're not totally sure
whether it's benign or not
we would randomize you into two groups a
group that has
just a standard of care and we follow
you over time that's our control group
or an intervention group and the
intervention group here will
offer some type of biomarker it could be
a clinical model
a blood biomarker or our imaging
biomarker
and our imaging biomarker will be
applied directly to the chest ct
that you have that you come to your
doctor with
we look at the imaging we run our
artificial intelligence tool and the
tool tells us that
no in fact you're not in the
intermediate risk you are
much lower risk you're in the low risk
group and we can follow you
you follow you safely with just
a chest ct that would be quite
reassuring
if the bowel marker our imaging lung
um artificial intelligence model tells
us no
your nigel is actually pretty high risk
we rather
you get a biopsy we'll follow these
strategies get the biopsy that your
doctors decide
on getting and eventually look at the
end point and in this
trial within two years we'll know
whether we're able to
improve the diagnostic accuracy
decrease the number the time it took us
to get the diagnosis and reduce the
number of invasive procedures
so this is the goal of where we want to
take these candidate biomarkers now
the biomarkers can be found in the blood
like
a protein or a dna testing or a
genomic test in the circulation of
your blood and we can test these
biomarkers following the same
clinical trial strategy here and
reclassify
your risk based on the results of the
biomarker into
low or high-risk group and then we will
be able to test the difference between
our intervention strategy versus the
control strategy
well with this um i want to finish by
telling you that ultimately we want
biomarkers into the clinical arena
they need to be non-invasive we need to
demonstrate that we improve the
management
by showing fuel morbidity and
decreasing the number of expensive
procedures
we want to improve the decision making
we watch and wait or we biopsy and we
want to make sure that we have the right
population that we're focusing on
and we want to test the technology that
the same time is quite
sensitive and that is specific as well
tells us that this nigel is a cancer we
better not make a mistake
and take you to surgery for the wrong
reason
to answer these questions of clinical
utility we need
a clinical trial and this is what i'm
currently working on with a number of
collaborators
so with this i want to conclude and i
think i told you that the biomarkers
have different layers of evidence
in my opinion those that are valuable
are better than the standard of care
which i showed you with this artificial
intelligence
tool the diagnostic biomarkers
should not have harm and it should be
offered to patients in the shared
decision making we need to discuss
the accuracy and the performance of the
biomarkers
and accept some or some uncertainty of
any
new biomarker that we bring into a
clinical study
patients must be willing to participate
into this
and i think when we want to scale up
this type of testing
we want to partner with the industry
because they are
very good at eventually bringing some of
these candidate biomarkers to the clean
coal
bedside and have those eventually
approved by the fda
so with this i want to
tell you that we need randomized
clinical trials
also in the diagnostic setting we want
to work with
people with clinical expertise and we
want to make sure that the patients
are involved in the design of these
studies and then we're honoring their
wishes
so in my final slide here is to say that
we talked about how do we personalize
the risk
we need an informed consent we want to
keep it simple
we want to work with statistical models
that are very necessary to help us
assess the strength and robustness of
our biomarkers
we need to look at the continuous risk
factors
and risk prediction models to eventually
find a solution
to address the shortcomings of our
current evaluation of lung nodules
i want to thank all the patients who are
participating in the studies that i've
presented here
and a large number of collaborators
without which i could not do this
work and these involve people who are
research coordinators
biostatisticians clinicians
imagers of course people expert in
biomarkers
uh biorepository chemistry
epidemiology and and screening in
general
so i want to thank the funding support
and my
collaborators and you all for listening
to me today
and hopefully i've provided you with
some good hopes
that not only lung cancer is a
big cancer mortality problem
but we are trying to tackle it with new
early detection methods
and in these detection methods chess ct
screening
seems to be remarkably efficient we want
to
keep improving its efficacy by bringing
biomarkers to non-invasively
diagnose the disease early and bring it
to a treatment
so with this i want to thank everybody
and
wish you a very good day i'd be happy to
take any questions
at this point and back to you kristin
thank you pierre for that outstanding
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of our webinar
now as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q a box
okay pierre our first question is there
any strategy
for early detection among smokers
so among smokers the best strategy is
to convince them to quit smoking that
sounds
a little facetious but it's the truth
and it could be the priority number one
two and three
once the people are high risk
meaning that over the age of 55 they've
smoked
for about 30 years or back a day or so
and that they quit less than 15 years
they should undergo lung cancer
chest ct screening and this is not a
one-time
test this is a process a surveillance
program
over time over long periods of time
until
there's no need for screening anymore so
yes there is a strategy for smokers
now for non-smokers that's a different
uh
problem we currently do not have
a good strategy for early detection of
lung cancer
among non-smokers and those people
represent about 10 15 of the population
it's a larger population in southeast
asia
where up to 30 of the people diagnosed
with lung cancer are never smokers it's
a very important
problem to tackle and we need to do a
lot more research in that space
thank you now what's the biggest
challenge in developing
biomarkers for lung cancer
the biggest challenge to develop
biomarkers
in my opinion is designing the studies
early on right
and choosing the population that you
want to bring your biomarker
in judiciously let me give you an
example
if you want to find a biomarker for
early detection of lung cancer
i would not start looking for biomarkers
in people with very advanced stage
disease
who don't undergo screening i would try
to
design studies to find the biomarker
in the population that you intend to
screen
that's very important the second is that
you need to have
a very sensitive method because
chest ct screening is actually pretty
sensitive to fine
nodules but when we find nodules we know
that the disease has been there for
months
so ultimately you want to be exquisitely
sensitive
and find a disease very early but the
problem when you're very sensitive
is that you may find some false positive
you may be mistakenly taking a nodule
for a cancer when in fact it's a small
infection
so that brings me to specificity which
means that
when the disease when the nodule is
called the cancer it must be a cancer
okay so and that
if i call it negative it's not a cancer
i'd better be
for sure that this is not a cancer so
this specificity is very important these
two metrics are very important
and another important part is to bring
the biomarkers
to clinical utility meaning that
it's not good enough to have a good
marker that discriminate one from the
other it has to be better than the
standard of care
and most biomarkers fail at that level
because to be standard of care is hard
it's like
athletes when you get good in athletics
and you know
you know you could be a wonderful
basketball player but to make
uh the state warriors team you need to
be at the very best
and few are elected in that zone so
that's where we want to be thank you for
that answer
and what does clinical utility mean
well clinical utility um means something
different from different people in
general
but if i ask you what it means you
probably tell me well something that'd
be good for me
and that's the right answer in
medicine and in biomarkers research
clinical utility
has different layers one
could think that if i manage to diagnose
a lung cancer at an earlier stage
it may be clinically useful but
if that bowel marker gets me an earlier
stage
without being better from what we're
already doing
it's not good enough so here the
benchmark is not big enough
what's the next benchmark the benchmark
would say okay it's better than
standard of care well that would be
terrific already people start
commercializing the biomarker
but it may not be good enough because it
may then may not demonstrate that we're
actually saving lives
ultimately we want to save lives
well people say well maybe that's too
high of a bar
and you may want to lower the bar a
little bit and say well at least if
we're saving money
in managing long nodules you would reach
a reasonable
clinical utility benchmark and so
it depends on who you're talking to it's
a very difficult uh
concept clinical utility has many many
different layers and many different
uh meaning to different people but to
most patients
is pretty simple it's whether this is
going to help me
in managing the disease better than
everything else that's out there at the
moment
and here we have time for one more
question i'd like to go with this last
one
where would you think biomarkers fall in
the future
in comparison to imaging well
i'm sh i'm pretty sure that biomarkers
have a world
now the technologies are getting better
and better we're getting more sensitive
at detecting very very subtle
differences between groups
we are getting very very good at
detecting minute traces of
abnormal molecules in our blood
it's true for proteins is true for
transcripts rna is trophy dna
it's true for mutilated dna or marks on
the dna
it's true for metabolites that we can
detect in the blood
i think the technology keeps improving
and will bring
very early weakness of that
disease that's circulating somewhere now
the challenge
that the biomarkers again
need to add complementary information to
what we already know
and um in many diseases
we see that biomarkers are growing in
their
importance you see this in
cardiovascular medicine
in diabetes management in the management
of
anti-autoimmune diseases
you see this in the management of many
many diseases biomarkers are coming to
the forefront
because they're molecular and they are
beyond the macroscope
they're beyond what traditional medicine
can do
yet they have a tough mark and is to
show
added value to the current standards and
this is the
uh biggest challenge we have in
biomarkers research i have no doubt that
some type of non-invasive biomarkers is
going to help us
diagnose lung cancer in a non-invasive
way and will add value to imaging
and by the way imaging is improving
every day too
so we have better resolution scanners
multiple detectors
a very small voxel density we're going
to get artificial intelligence models
better than the one i showed you
and we're going to be not just looking
at the nodule we're going to look at the
entire patient
and maybe it is that the emphysema
that's associated with the nodule that's
going to give us even more information
so we have a lot more study to be done
in the biomarkers field biomarkers that
are either
molecular based or imaging based
so there's a lot of hope for the future
and the future is
coming very quickly it's assumed that
we'll see
these differences
that it is dr massion and thank you so
much for this excellent presentation and
very detailed q a session i also want to
thank our audience for
their outstanding questions we hope that
you have found today's presentation to
be informative
and insightful today's presentation will
be available for on-demand viewing
also don't miss out on the other
valuable presentations on our agenda
just visit that agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and dr museum thank you
thank you again for your time until next
time everyone
have a great day bye bye bye it was my
pleasure thank you
thank you